the release of the matrix resurrections
is just around the corner and neo is all
set to return but how keep watching for
a look at the once backstory for a
refresher on where we left off
in the 21st century the earth is
devastated by a war between humanity and
the artificial intelligence they once
enslaved the machines then begin
capturing and eventually growing human
beings and use their bodies energy as
fuel the war ends with the machines
conquering the planet and humanity
becoming essentially livestock bred by
the machines and living their entire
lives in individual tanks to harvest
their heat and electrical energy better
to keep the humans dustle a sentient
program called the architect devises a
simulated reality called the matrix to
keep human minds busy and unaware of
their captivity the human mind can
detect the unreality of the matrix so
each prisoner is given a subconscious
choice to accept or reject their
simulated reality
nearly 99 of prisoners choose the
illusion which helps to sustain it as a
consensus reality the remaining one or
two percent of humans unknowingly reject
the simulation most without even knowing
it use their collective disbelief to
create an imbalance known as the
architect's equation to counter the
imbalance the architect allows it to
accumulate in isolation once this
remainder from its grand equation
becomes too great to contain the matrix
randomly selects one human being to
embody it
this person is known as the one an
extraordinary individual is born who can
learn to reshape the matrix at will this
figure awakens and frees a number of
humans to the real world once the one
meets the architect and has told the
truth about their nature they are given
a choice to either cooperate in
perpetuating the cycle of control or to
allow the matrix to collapse killing all
of humanity given two terrible options
the one chooses to repair the matrix so
that it can be rebooted safely each set
of freed humans believe that they are
the first resistance released by the
original one and destined to discover
their reincarnation
in fact they are playing out a story
written by their enemy over and over
again all five iterations of the one
before neo chose to surrender to those
machines and restart the cycle the story
of the matrix trilogy begins with the
emergence of the sixth one neo who was
the first to make a different choice as
long as the matrix exists
the human race will never be free
like most humans neo was born in a vat
in one of the machines farms his brain
is jacked into the matrix from birth and
he is raised as thomas anderson another
unremarkable citizen of mega city he
becomes a professional computer
programmer and moonlights as a hacker
under the alias neo neo can sense that
there's something wrong with the world
he lives in and spends his nights
searching the internet for clues as to
its true nature this search puts him on
the trail of a wanted terrorist known as
morpheus who as it turns out has also
been looking for him morpheus reaches
out to neo via his most trusted disciple
trinity herself a famous and formidable
hacker trinity offers to help neo find
answers to his questions but their
meeting attracts the attention of the
authorities who come to arrest him at
his workplace the next day morpheus
attempts to guide him to safety but neo
does not have the courage to manage his
escape and is captured by the shadowy
group known as the agents while in
government custody neo is interrogated
by the sinister agent smith for
information about morpheus when neo
refuses to cooperate smith demonstrates
a terrifying influence over reality
literally sealing neo's mouth shut and
implanting him with a strange squid-like
tracking device leo wakes up at home
afterward and dismisses his entire
encounter as a dream until trinity and
her crew show him otherwise hungrier
than ever for answers neo agrees to meet
with morpheus who offers him a choice
represented by two pills if neo takes
the blue pill he will return to his
ordinary life and never hear from
morpheus again if he takes the red pill
morpheus will give him the answers he
seeks but there can be no going back neo
chooses knowledge but is completely
unprepared for the terrifying truth soon
he wakes up in the real world a place
he's never known this isn't real
what is real
how do you define real
leo joins the crew of the nebuchadnezzar
a hovercraft commanded by morpheus in
the service of the underground human
resistance in addition to defending zion
the last human city resistance fighters
broadcast their consciousness back into
the matrix in order to liberate the
humans who are still trapped there one
by one re-entering the matrix as a free
mind grants them the ability to bend or
even break the physical rules of the
simulation the nebuchadnezzar's
technology can even download complex
skill sets directly into their brains
making them expert warriors overnight
with practice this will allow neo to
return to the matrix as the impossibly
cool action hero like trinity and the
rest of the crew but morpheus has even
bigger plans for him
it's unknown how morphy has come to
suspect neo of being the one but
morpheus is certain that neo is the
prophesized reincarnation of humanity's
savior morpheus brings neo back into the
matrix to meet the oracle who privately
confirms neo's doubts about himself neo
doesn't believe he's the one and
therefore he isn't morpheus however
refuses to hear this and when the crew
come under attack by agents morpheus
allows himself to be captured so that
neo can escape neo isn't willing to
accept this sacrifice auntie and trinity
embark on a mission to rescue morpheus
from agent smith's clutches neo and
trinity shoot kick and blast away
through armed security and successfully
return morpheus his consciousness to his
body in the real world neo however gets
cut off from their escape route and is
forced to fight agent smith one-on-one
smith like all agents is a program
endowed with strength speed and
endurance beyond even what a fully
trained resistance fighter can achieve
neo wins a hand-to-hand battle and
nearly escapes back into the real world
but it's not enough smith recovers and
shoots neo dead
back in the real world aboard the
nebuchadnezzar trinity stands over neo's
apparently dead body and whispers a
secret into his ear yarokuwens told her
that she would fall in love with a man
and that man would be the one trinity
confesses that she's fallen in love with
neo therefore neo is the one
i love you
[Music]
through the power of this belief neo's
vital stabilized and his projected self
inside the matrix springs back to life
more powerful than ever neo can now see
the code behind the matrix rubric speeds
around fathomable even to agents and
stop a hail of bullets with a thought
with his newfound understanding of the
matrix neo dives into agent smith's body
and seemingly destroys his program from
the inside
six months after neo's death and
resurrection is the one a massive
machine army approaches zion with no
hope of winning this physical
confrontation the crew of the
nebuchadnezzar embarks on a mission to
help neo reach the source which the
oracle tells them will help them to win
the machine war they are led to the key
maker who creates a back door in the
matrix through which neo can access the
source in order to ensure this
operation's success trinity is forced
into battle with an agent and is
mortally wounded when neo steps through
the back door meets another program the
architect here the architect reveals a
terrible truth that the one is actually
part of the machine's plan another
system of control the architect offers
neo the same choice that he's offered
the five previous subjects of the prime
program he can return his code to the
source and restart the cycle for another
century or refuse and allow the matrix
to degrade and wipe out humanity every
previous incarnation of the one has been
driven by compassion a general feeling
of love that led them to choose the
long-term survival of the species neo
however is in love with an individual
and can't bear to lose her rather than
perpetuate the cycle of the one neo
hurries back to the matrix and to
trinity reviving her moments after death
just as she once did for him neo's
choice means that the matrix now has an
expiration date but it also means the
fight for humanity's freedom can
continue
meanwhile an additional threat grows
from within the matrix that poses a
danger to both humanity and the machines
smith after being decompiled by neo
smith is reconstituted in the matrix
which reflexively recodes him as a
counterbalance against the power of the
one smith gains the ability to rewrite
the digital avatars of other programs or
even human beings creating countless
copies of himself that share a single
consciousness smith spreads like a
plague across the matrix smith gains
such a power in the matrix that the
machines have no counter against his
influence the oracle predicts that
smith's rage and thirst for power will
eventually consume not only the matrix
but the real world even the source
itself
seems like every time we meet
i got nothing but bad news
after neo resuscitates trinity the
couple returns to the real world but
they escape from the nebuchadnezzar
moments before machine sentinels destroy
it to everyone's surprise even neos neo
is able to incapacitate a sentinel with
his mind he determines that he can use
his newfound abilities to journey safely
through machine territory to the
physical home of the source trinity
refuses to let neo take this dangerous
journey alone and accompanies him for
the voyage aboard the hovercraft logos
however the logos also has a third
passenger smith who has stowed away via
the hijacked human body of bane he
attacks neo and permanently blinds him
with a bare electrical cable while his
eyes have been burnt out neo can still
see machine code including smith this
allows him to kill smith's new body and
to serve as trinity's navigator for the
rest of the flight sadly neo's abilities
prove insufficient to protect the logos
from the machine city's defenses the
logo's crashes fatally wounding trinity
this time there's nothing to do but give
their tier 4 goodbyes after a final kiss
trinity dies and neo is forced to
complete their quest alone
neo travels to the heart of the machine
city and confronts deus ex machina the
machine figurehead neo offers to
re-enter the matrix and rid it of the
threat of smith in exchange for an end
to the war the machine invasion of zion
holds while neo does battle with smith
who has now assimilated the entire
population of mega city smith now has
the ability to see the future and is
certain that the fight will end with
neo's death the battle rages and smith
appears to get the upper hand neo
recognizes that the solution is to allow
smith to assimilate his code smith
absorbs neo therefore allowing deus ex
machina to destroy him and reboot the
system this appears to kill neo as well
but smith is seemingly erased restoring
mega city and all the programs rewritten
during his rampage the matrix has reborn
apparently under new terms that will
permit humans to leave if they so choose
this as it turns out has been the
oracle's intention since the beginning
of this cycle like everyone else she
placed her faith in neo and her faith
was rewarded as the trilogy closes the
oracle says that she suspects that
she'll see neo again someday neo is
indeed set to return in the matrix
resurrections though the nature of his
appearance in the film remains to be
seen so we'll just have to wait and see
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movie characters are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]